hi I'm Nicolas P and this is the reason
podcast please subscribe to us at iTunes
and rate and review us while you're
there today I'm pleased to introduce one
of the two greatest libertarians in this
conversation the best-selling author PJ
O'Rourke whose latest book how the hell
did this happen chronicles the most
insane year ever in American politics
PJ thanks for talking to us oh you're
very welcome okay and I rush to add that
I'm actually calling you from a place
that you used to call home back in the
day Oxford Ohio home to Miami University
your alma mater whatever what you
remember most about Miami University uh
it's all the stuff that I can't remember
that really it's kind of fun right yes
yeah there there are some some very
pleasant blurry patches back there
British and Sonny German and English
English I was looking through the course
syllabus we didn't in those days didn't
you didn't have to decide to like the
end of your sophomore year or something
what your major was and I'm looking
through the course syllabus I I came
across English and I want I speak that
oh how hard can it be
do you I'm you have kids and college age
kids post college age kids I've got a
college cousin two that are younger okay
but do you will you insist that they go
to college and learn how to become an
engineer or something useful or do you
actually find something meaningful in
looking at the humanities or the Social
Sciences or something like no that's
what I insist on them you know I mean
even my eldest daughter is somewhat
business minded now I'm trying to keep
her out of business school I says you
know honey there's time for that if you
want to get your MBA later it really
doesn't matter what your prior what your
undergraduate is a chance to really
immerse yourself well be immersed in in
the history of civilization you know in
literature in the arts
you're going to be forced march to these
things some that's going to be boring
something that you won't appreciate for
another 40 years
but it's the
the lack College liberal arts education
is the last chance you really get to - I
mean you can teach yourself but I've
found with a lot of things that I've
taught myself that I needed a better
professor yes that explains why when I
turned the lights on in half of my house
something pops and everything goes dark
yes and it explains my carpentry which
my wife has exiled to you know the
garage shelf Department occasionally
allowed to do something inside a closet
watch out you know that's a those were
David Carradine's last words I think who
has a sound brightest in a in a Thai
hotel room closet I believe oh I forgot
about that
oh thank you well here let me ask you
before we start talking about the large
themes about how how the hell did this
happen and it's fantastic to have you as
our kind of Virgil
through what I really do hope is the
worst year ever because you know we've
got there's still a future ahead of us
where things could always get worse but
do you consider yourself more of a
libertarian or conservative and where
where do you see the borderline between
those kind of concepts or ideologies
overlapping where's that where's the
no-man's land for you oh well it really
depends upon from what angle we're
looking at things politically I consider
myself primarily to be a libertarian I
am personally conservative I'm
conservative about religion I'm
conservative about moral values I'm
probably even somewhat conservative in a
more conservative than many libertarians
are in foreign policy but when it comes
to the rule of law and the construct of
politics and the way that politics and
the individual I always think of
libertarianism is basically being an
analytical tool not an ideology per se
but an analytical tool so when you look
at something that happens especially in
politics
we look at something happens you say
does this increase the dignity of the
individual does this increase the
liberty of the individual does this
increase the responsibility of the
individual and it meets those three
criteria then it's probably an
acceptable libertarian political policy
or lack thereof because you know we like
to subtract some things from politics -
well you wrote on these themes you wrote
an absolutely amazing piece for the
Weekly Standard which it appears or is
pulled out of the book how the hell did
this happen which is on sale at Amazon
bookstores everywhere and but an amazing
piece for The Weekly Standard called the
revolt look against the elites and the
limits of populism thank you note that
even in well-behaved countries you know
relatively speaking such as Australia
and France and whatnot populism is
rising and people are sick of being
treated as cogs in some kind of Davos
devotee or attendees banker money-making
machine what is good about the new
populism for you and what scares you
about it
well let's talk about the good because
it's a lot first because it's more
limited the the it's definitely true
that the I think there's a worldwide
animus going on against the elites and
part of this is because of the shift in
the in the economy the shift sort of
toward a much more high tech economy is
leaving a lot of people who have manual
skills and or simply the capacity for
hard labor it is leaving them way behind
and you know this is something that that
people it needs to be addressed needs to
be recognized because it can it's not so
much actually that the divide between
the rich and poor has gotten greater
this actually been tremendous strides
around the world at abolishing the worst
level of poverty
we're affecting the numbers come people
with living on a buck or a buck 50 a day
and the number of those people has come
down very considerably but they they're
feeling a sort of obscene an
aspirational ceiling the fact that a lot
of it has to do with lack of rule of law
in places not only in utter ly chaotic
places like say Somalia or Sudan but in
in very crops places like Russia and
China is making people very angry and I
think that's where something I mean your
rule of laws is something that's
fundamental to a free society define
rule of law do you mean that you know
that the rules apply to everybody same
rule exactly exactly and you can
actually keep sort of extrapolate from
this that it doesn't even it doesn't
have to be perfect law that as long as
the rules of the society apply to to to
everybody there there is a kind of
justice in the air but when there is an
exception because of wealth or power or
holiness or fame you know if there is a
mechanism by which somebody can step
outside the Justice Department then then
that law is lousy no matter how
liberally written no matter how
carefully you know no matter how
merciful it is or how just it is if
people can avoid it that law is bad
so that first is when when China first
moved into aa in into a free-market sort
of situation and before the level of
corruption had risen so high there was a
period where you could look at China and
say well at least they have rule of law
number good rule of laws Kinnaman square
clearly pointed out it's not a place
you'd choose to lever a system that you
would you would design in your mind as
being ideal but that law does seem to
apply
to everybody from gang down but that
went away pretty quickly well what about
in you know you talk about countries
like France Hungary is one Russia
certainly one the United States England
these are also places that are
experiencing real paroxysms of populism
and I'm sorry to be illiterate oftheir
you know and is it say at America you
know is it it's not it's not the super
poor people it seems to be that the
people who feel left behind this is the
people that Hillary ignored Hillary
Clinton ignored and Donald Trump spoke
to directly and said I'm going to help
you yes yeah it hardly a function of
advanced economies and people being you
know actually I would say well a couple
things going on well one thing sets us
apart from Europe Europe is suffering
from a just tremendous refugee crisis
that the governmental elites of Europe
have completely failed to address
they've failed to address its cause they
failed to address its facts they failed
to address its after-effects they failed
to address its intentional and it's
unintentional effects they just have
just completely screwed things up and I
think that problem we holds the key to
the brexit vote was NPR which was you
know MP Irish but nonetheless they do a
good job and they did an afterword sort
of you know exit poll where they went
around to places that have voted heavily
for brexit and the response was was was
was pretty much across the board it
wasn't racist
it wasn't violent it wasn't xenophobic
but it was this isn't the Britain that I
grew up in you know things are changing
they're changing it's obviously a fear
of what was going on in Germany what was
going on in France a fear of that taking
hold in Britain that you know made
people want to separate themselves here
I think it's more directly an effective
expansion of government to the point
where
government is just as its thumb and
every conceivable apply I mean it's just
we are so complexly regulated that it's
driving people crazy and people that is
driving crazy are the core Trump voters
they tend to be a small business people
skilled often highly skilled blue-collar
I mean you know that their incomes
wouldn't indicate that their blue-collar
their education might not but these
living like craftsmen were they are the
plumbers and electricians and maybe
master electrician's made master parts
but you know they may only be in a son
I'm talking to people who are at Trump
rallies and I found like I could kid
with them you know I mean you know this
Trump was not my choice and I know I was
at best I was talking to a guy and he
said dammit I own up gas station and a
towing operation and he says just me and
my wife I don't have like III don't have
a human services department I don't have
a you know legal department he said
every time some jerk in Washington
passes some new idea he does never seems
to think that it means another pile of
paperwork on my desk and a nice
paperwork's left does he have to give
his wife paid maternity leave now
probably yeah I mean and he said then
you know I've got old gas tanks at my
gas station and I need I can't get the
local state and federal comets to get
them removed I can tree get the local
state and federal permits to install new
ones he said this you know this is just
me I'm regulated from every conceivable
direction he said I can afford he had a
fair number of employees he said I can
afford the Obamacare he said but I can't
afford us the paperwork that comes with
it that's not what I do and you know and
he says you need company pieces just me
am i and so I really like the guy and we
got to talking about some other stuff
and so on the side finally I said to him
so electing a maniac fixes this how and
he laughed it
said I don't know but you know the the
hell with a bunch of them you know I'm
bumper Trump you and you scandalously at
least in certainly the reason offices
you scandalously endorsed Hillary or you
said you wouldn't vote for Trump because
of da and I did vote for Hillary did for
how did that feel okay well it was a
matter of us I may say so reason it was
I looked at this you know the in the
commodity market there's something
called the VIX the volatility index you
can actually buy a predictions of how
volatile the markets will be and they
call it the fear index you can actually
buy and sell fear on the commodity index
and I looked at the volatility of the
two candidates and I thought I know with
probably about 98 99 percent assurance
exactly what I'm getting with Hillary
I loathe them to test it but we just
survived eight years of it I doubt it
will last more than four more it's very
rare for American political cycles to
last longer than twelve years as poor
George HW Bush proved and I said you
know we survived eight years of it we
can survive another four I know what's
coming I looked over Trump and I said I
have no idea I just have no idea he
might turn out to be an absolutely
ordinary president you know I don't like
this populist noise I particularly hated
the xenophobia I mean the that that was
probably if I had to put one finger on
the thing about Trump was the the
scapegoating noise he did this stuff
about refugees and stuff about
immigrants and so on
I mean did we learn nothing from that
horrible period between World War one
and World War two
I I'm Pro him a good guy I mean it's
yeah I will listen to anti-immigrant
talk from a full-blooded American Indian
and nobody
they've got a beef it's well let's talk
a specifically about Donald Trump a
little bit
you've likened him to Juan Peron the
authoritarian socialist who helped
transform Argentina from one of the
wealthiest countries in the world really
to a second-tier [ __ ] hall and it's
never really calm down of that it's
actually I like it Evita
yes well I was going to say if Trump has
launched Iran does that mean Melania is
Evita and you don't know if my Trump
loses Trump was Evita I said actually we
had a pair of them I said you know it
was we were definitely we're definitely
going through a period in global
politics where there's kind of a an
accent on the strong person Malkin if he
starts wearing a you know a military
uniform with braids on it one wouldn't
put it past them and I think he could do
it but no I I thought he was more of a
it is my sincere hope that we're having
history repeated us which comes first
his tragedy and then is repeated his
comedy so I'm hoping that we're in handy
Lloyd Webber musical - exactly I'm
hoping we're in the Andrew Lloyd Webber
version of the period between World War
One World War two
so what friends you most of that Trump
you I mean because you've said also that
we're not in a teachable moment because
we're too scared of everything we're
scared of foreigners were scared of the
pace of technological change the rise of
addicted people you've talked about how
a lot of the people have been left
behind I think at one point you talked
about how the the Kenmore Appliance
repairman is you know he can't he can't
picture a refrigerator because he's he's
down and out on oxycontin or heroin
what yeah but most fears disappeared yes
like well you know this is you take the
bad with the good right yeah somebody
can be dressed exclusively in tough
skins as a child was happy to see at
least that part of Sears going away but
what what I mean you've talked about the
xenophobia and Trump and you obviously
like the idea that he could you know put
you start a nuclear war or a war war but
what else I mean is there a broader
sensibilities no well this was just not
a small government guy by personality
buy whatever passes for ideology with
him I mean this is like a big brush
stroke person and I don't have any use
for that you know I want I want the
government to shrink in the wash
and I want it both cleaner and smaller
please and white and now you're going to
have you join a succes well no it is not
where I'm going at all as a matter fact
the knowledge matter-of-fact of anything
I wanted to
I want the nation to be more colorful I
mean I just see IP I mean at the core of
libertarianism as an attitude and as a
as a you know as a big way of thinking
about politics is the idea that people
are assets this is all about people and
that people should our assets and and
should be treated as assets not as you
know and the liberal idea is that people
are burdens you know more sick people
means more government expense more poor
people emergence of more government
expense more any kind of people means
more government expense
whereas I I think you know me means more
growth more vitality and and I guess
Trump then from this position it's you
know because obviously Democrats and
liberals more broadly as well as
progressives are really you know they're
going after him with everything that God
you and that he's a student you sure are
yeah but but the point of whatever he's
one of them yeah that's explore that a
little bit or explain that a little bit
well yeah I mean he's one of them but
he's coming at it from a sort of like
populist
throw down the ladder you know I got
mine effuge you know he's there's a you
know a segment of America that feels
threatened by change change of all kinds
and he's saying well I'm going to make
things like they they used to be but the
tools that he's going to use huge
infrastructure spending you know serve
big
gigs everywhere you know and won't be
just confined to Boston you'll get them
in Terre Haute Indiana
you know the big image rise in military
budget I mean we already spend more than
the other top what is it ten countries
combined the immune army we may have a
foreign policy it doesn't make any sense
but you don't want to mess with our
military and you know he's a big
government guys a big government guy for
small-minded people and the Liberals are
so mad at him because they regard
themselves as large minded people but
you know of course they are equally big
government it's just well you know which
part of the government do you want to
increase do you want to Mew no build an
aircraft carrier or more transgender
bathrooms right no that was something
else somebody said to me one on the
campaign trail at a trump rally he said
talking about failure of the elites he
said damn it he said I'm in the logging
business I am so regulating again he
like many people I talked to he talked
about regulation but at the end of it he
said you know and I turn on the TV at
night and what's the lead news story
it's about transgender bathrooms we
don't have any bathrooms in the woods
why what do you do with that I mean I
guess you know you wrote and let me
quote from something you wrote you said
a person of libertarian inclinations can
understand and sympathize with the
revolt against the elites and obviously
that's what you did on the campaign
trail you were talking to the bevel
talking back but then you said so far
the revolt is not promoting an increase
in individual dignity individual freedom
and individual responsible
responsibility it's doing the opposite
and you also talk about populism as a
libertarian tragedy and I think you know
from what you've been talking about it
makes sense but then how do you how do
you answer how did you answer the guy
who was you know protest about the
transgender bathrooms to get to it stuff
that is actually going to change his
situation as well as you know
transgender people's yeah well
fortunately I wasn't there campaigning
for Rand Paul or I would have had to
a dress that I mean I was just there as
a reporter so the way I responded to him
was by writing what he said down and it
was I mean there was like a weird sort
of like personal breakthrough moment I
had with it with the garage guy yeah
that I felt like I could like talk to
him man-to-man you know but he just
obviously one of those people with
obvious evident good sense of humor and
you know I make him sound really grumpy
but he wasn't he didn't have that effect
actually in person but yeah I mean hi
when one of the things that it takes
unfortunately given the nature of our
political system and our political
tradition you need somebody who is like
really good at getting this stuff across
the way Ronald Reagan was and I mean ice
I would prefer things to be so that what
I could tell you was well we just we
have to do more libertarian education we
have to do more libertarian outreach
we've got to get younger people who have
libertarian inclinations more engaged in
this but in fact it requires the kind of
leadership that was not provided by Gary
Johnson talking about me I mean he was
not inspired ran a terrible campaign
yeah there were so many moments
it seemed to me over this campaign cycle
that lasted for two years when
libertarian stuff could catch fire and
it didn't I had some hope for Rand Paul
but um
Rand is unfortunately burdened burdened
by intellect in a way I mean you ask a
random question and you get the whole
answer and while that's great
for an interview it's not great on the
stump who did you you don't get the joke
you know that you got from Reagan you
don't get you don't get the thing boiled
down who who did you see I mean because
you you were covering
everybody on the campaign and yeah I
think you you had the nicest I think you
were the nicest of Ben Carson who is
kind of a comedy minefield but music a
couple like Ted Cruz you know that he's
the type of guy who is you know giving a
kind of Billy Sunday sermon inside the
tent while his friends are around the
back picking about Christian camp girls
but was there anybody on the hustings
whether you know on the fringes of
Hillary's campaign were in the
Republican Party or anywhere who you
thought could you even stitch a
character together from all of these
different people that would that would
do what you what you wanted no I think
we ran probably came closest and he's
just have to be seasoned and oak longer
you know hey not hot you know yeah I
mean well on the funny sort of way not
talk as much for talking her directly
you know actually I was I was impressed
by by by a number of the Republicans
that I saw were pretty impressive in
small town hall meeting situations
includes Jeb Bush and Marco Rubio
actually were Jeb Bush was very
plausibly presidential you know little
probably of the more more moderate wing
of the Republican Party less libertarian
wing of the Republican Party than me but
uh and some of the most likable I really
dumped on Mike Huckabee which I feel bad
about because I like Huckabee but he
just ran an awful sort of social
conservative campaign when that was not
what was on people's mind the I was
impressed with Marco Rubio he kind of
went off the rails there I think because
of inexperience and nervousness but I
actually saw him at st. Anselm College
up here with a fairly large group and he
not only was he did he give a good talk
but he then did a long queue a
a session with some very grumpy voters
and he was very patient with his
explanations he should have seemed to
show some grasp of libertarian ideas
yeah I've seen him give speeches that
had the hair on the back of my neck
rising up he can he can sell it when he
has to that's for sure yeah yeah but
except that I don't think your phrase is
exactly right he can sell it but he
can't always summon it yeah you know he
can't always summon that pitch it's not
reliable for him
so he also needing to get he needs to be
doping before every game right someday
yes yes exactly yeah well yeah why don't
you know in in some of your writings you
talk about the pace of technological
change seems different over the past
eight 30 or 40 years and that in the
digitally or Internet era that change is
more disruptive yeah and you've
underscored you know that techno
technological innovation is always
disruptive but there was something
linear to the Industrial Revolution you
see a train then you see a car what's
going on that's different now explain
how you know kind of past technological
revolutions or innovations which really
have a profound impact on the culture on
the society on the politics how they
were different and then why it's
different now and how we might grapple
with that more more fruitfully than we
had well are the two examples of two
prior technological examples that I
would use first there was an
agricultural revolution at the at the
end of the of the mill in the late
Middle Ages which arguably led to the
Renaissance Adam Smith makes that
argument no wealth of nations and then
of course the Industrial Revolution we
know how disruptive dark satanic Mills
and all that that the Industrial
Revolution was but the thing that to
understand about those revolutions was
first they were slow especially the
Agricultural Revolution was
it was very gradual so gradual that it
wasn't until a couple hundred years
later that people really could realize
that it had happened the Industrial
Revolution was much faster but it worked
on very basic principles of mechanics
that that your average Plowman could
look at this machine and see how it
worked and it was linear as you said I
mean once you had seen a railroad how
surprised could you be about by an
automobile you know Jesus booked a
locomotive off its track
the and so that the Industrial
Revolution was comprehensible to people
it happened fairly quickly but not
nearly as quickly as the IT revolution
are they you know the electronic
revolution or the internet revolution
whatever you want caught and that would
be the the side effects of this very
quick technological change have been
exceedingly unpredictable I mean who at
the onset of the Internet would predict
that it would make them the anchor store
at the local mall go away I mean it has
these totally surprising effects on
people's lives and their jobs and in its
spreads fear even to people who have
nothing to fear you know I mean nursing
care cannot be replaced by Facebook
right but on but Apple agents you know
they're like who we were the travel
agent right yeah exactly except to the
auto work travel agent in them and uh
everybody feel is feeling that this is
uh pending their business and even when
their business uh I was in and out being
treated for a while but at a Dartmouth
at Murray Hitchcock up there and they
had just gotten a brand new computer
system at umpteen million dollars that
was really working well for them and the
federal government came in and mandated
that they changed a computer system they
had to spend another umpteen
in dollars and of course everybody you
know from from the candy-striper girl
right to the heart surgeon had to learn
how to use this new system they were
pissed you know nobody's job was in
danger but they were hurt and they were
you know from the highest administrative
level right down to the lowliest person
taking out that cut off arms and legs so
with you know libertarians are often
accused of being kind of Vulcan you know
in or descended from Vulcans not having
many emotions among not how do you and
you know there's some truth to that
and but how do you put the human back
into that disruption because you're I
think explaining extremely well where
the kind of populism anger comes from
but it's not even necessarily government
policy I mean it is in the case of
saying I could put in a new computer
system but Amazon was started and
rightly our in face of government
restrictions yeah so how do we get back
to the human because we a dozed off to
deny you know the fact that Amazon is
kind of a [ __ ] great absolutely you
know I mean we we all use it you know
once I mean you know we're voting with
our fingers we're voting with our credit
cards or whatever you know I mean it's
raw in favor of it obviously even though
it may be this you know it cost us a job
at one end but got us a cheap couch at
the other you know I mean it's like you
know I push push me pull you sort of
situation I think this is one of the
reasons that this was a very tough
election for libertarians because it's
hard for libertarians we're in favor of
progress or in favor of innovation and
who are in favor of free enterprise to
when when these things when disruption
is caused by these fundamentally good
things net good things but when they're
when they're macro good things I should
say but when they're causing disruption
at a micro level maybe we sometimes have
to rethink a little bit our position of
utter
in other non-interference in in in
people in people's lives you know this
is it certainly would be a time to for
libertarians to get in there and work
hard on getting rid of the kind of
regulations that put undue limits on any
kind of free enterprise small businesses
the growth of small businesses small
businesses shouldn't be penalized for
growing they shouldn't be zoned out of
existence you know they shouldn't be
regulated out of existence but
regulations that really don't matter I
have any you know effect you know so
it's kind of time to do that it's time
to do a certain amount of explaining and
it may be you know maybe there are
rational government interventions not to
prevent any of these things from
happening
but the ease the circumstances under
which they happen so I'm not enough I
mean that could be something ranging
from a kind of better or a different
type of social safety net and
libertarians historically are
comfortable with or a universal basic
income or you know we know the
government yeah it would be something in
that direction yeah to help people yeah
I mean I don't pretend to be enough of a
policy wonk to say which of these things
would be best or are not best I leave
that to the scholars at the Cato
Institution place with that but but but
I have a feeling that that you know that
that comfort can be can be given and and
and aid and assistance can be you know
so many kids are coming out of the
educational system ill-prepared for this
modern economy you know I mean right
there with school vouchers you've got a
you've got a good issue yeah do you I
mean are you optimistic it I mean I
think in the long run you know I guess
Keynes said famously in the long run
we're all dead
and I think my favorite Aryans ivory guy
yeah most libertarians I know it's like
in the long run you know it's the
singularity it just gets better and
better but over the next you know for
you for your kids adulthood are you
optimistic or you know is and is this a
you know it's not that there's going to
be one kind of you know rescission of a
government regulation that allows
everything to be good and you know in an
edition of a new program that might make
things better but you know what has to
have is it mostly a change in attitude
to understand that it you know cliche as
it is that change is the only constant
and that you know your kids are going to
have to learn three or four different
professions over the course of their
life and you know I think they're pretty
hip to that actually I and I don't think
that they're particularly frightened by
it and I think they're intrigued they of
course have a capacity that I at my age
don't you know to embrace embrace change
enthusiastically I mean you know it's
like when you're a 13 year old boy like
any changes could change a the house is
on fire
everything's exciting so I am actually
very optimistic but of course I had the
good fortune and this had to do with you
know making a decent income and also
with with the person I married to I had
the good fortune to ensure that my kids
had a good education or are getting a
good education and so they are going to
be prepared both specifically with
certain skills but more important
intellectually generally to cope with
the change and you know the change the
rate of change will slow down I mean
there's I already noticed certain things
with my kids like they are fatigued with
social medium they still use the hell
out of it but they are beginning to be
annoyed with it
and that to me is predictive my eldest
does a lot of online shopping but she's
very conservative with her money and
very sort of strict about using her own
money for her clothes purchases and she
and her friends have found all these
apps where they basically pass clothes
around in which I don't think augurs
well for the endless growth of the youth
fashion industry
yeah well this um the part of the
problem right with you know I mean I
guess there's one model we can look to
it's Europe which we might be twenty
years behind or so in terms of social
attitudes and the populist uprising and
nativism but then there's Japan which
has fewer people now but and had at the
turn of the century and shrinking yeah
it's an old I don't think either of
those are appropriate models for us I
mean Europe is so ingrained with its
fractional ISM and so over I mean its
proximity to all sorts of ugly customers
I mean you know it's you can practically
walk the war from anywhere in Europe you
know and and Japan is so such an
isolated society such an insular society
you know I mean we're for all the talk
to the contrary we're immigrant friendly
and we're an immigrant nation and while
we do have plenty of factions they do
all speak more or less the same language
more or less comprehensible to each
other and on are all you know are not
divided up the way that Europeans are
nor do we have this sort of loyalist
attitude that all good things ring down
upon us from the government which still
obtains in in in these ex-royal
countries even in France you know and
where you think they would know better
but so III think things things are going
to be fine but you know there's going to
be some trouble getting to the fine part
and libertarians
we may be fighting we may be fighting
some old battles I mean we may be
engaged there may be there's an element
of libertarianism that's still engaged
in a war with FDR and by that you mean
that we are hopefully we're not going to
be packin the Supreme Court but what
with entitlement spending things like
yeah yeah I mean well I mean these
things have to be addressed right they
absolutely have to be addressed in the
libertarians are in a very good position
to to address them but when it comes to
like certain sort of changes in the
nature of the relationship of the
individual to the state and many of us
are and I include myself you know I mean
we're still fighting the the fights that
Milton Friedman the fights that Hayek
and so on fought and I'm not saying that
those fights don't still need to be
fought but I'm saying there are also
other battles that we better get
ourselves involved in what what is the
first among those other battles the
first at this moment is it is economic
transition how do we enable this economy
to benefit most from the economic
changes that are going to happen anyway
right and that's where you're talking
about things like really getting past a
lot of accreted regulations that you
know we'd always and I mean in a way I
guess Trump Trump is speaking your
language when he says for every
regulation we pass we're getting rid of
- that's yeah not a bad idea yeah and a
that's not a bad idea I mean you know
the man is not with without some
insights and and and I don't know if we
go so far as to call them ideas but I
mean I mean he precedes some things and
he obviously he connects with with
people on supination it's not like he's
wrong about everything but he he can be
if he wants if he applies himself he can
be wrong about yeah he would seem to
have a talent for it yeah well let me
ask you know maybe well
and on this to you is any part of you
and your last big book was about about
the baby boom generation your generation
and you know is there any part of you
that misses the exiting of Bill and
Hillary Clinton from the stage of
national and world politics not one iota
not one iota is goodbye and don't let
the door hit you on the butt on the way
out you know what's your ears your hat
and yes and yeah well I hope you know I
hope that we can still remember that
when the nuclear Armageddon begins or
when Chelsea gets elected idea that that
will be a battle be at time - I think
rise - armed insurrection at that point
rather than jury yeah that's us when we
talk to our friends in Idaho well we
will leave it there we have been talking
with PJ O'Rourke he's the author most
recently of how the hell did this happen
which chronicles the last year in
American politics up through Donald
Trump's the surprising victory PJ thanks
so much for talking to us it is very
good to talk to you I'm Nick Gillespie
this has been the reason podcast please
subscribe to us in iTunes and thanks for
listening
you